- But first
I want you to meet Morgan
Harper Nichols, everybody.
She is an amazing poet.
Look at that hat and that little, okay.
She looks so cute in that picture too.
She is an amazing poet
a musician and artist
whose social media presence
has earned the devotion of
millions, including celebrities
like Reese Witherspoon
and Jennifer Garner.
Earlier this year, Morgan
announced she was autistic
and that sparked a conversation
on diagnosing autism
and adults, you know, hear
that, you know, as much.
And so she's also out
with a new book called
how far you have come.
Let's get her in here.
What's up. Morgan Harper,
Nichols. How you doing?
- Hello? Hello.
Thank you for having me.
I'm doing well. Doing well.
- Oh my God! You look great.
I love the like handkerchief here.
You're so cute.
Yes, it's awesome.
So you're a very successful artist
but until this diagnosis,
you really struggled, right?
- Yes. So I grew up struggling
with a lot of sensory issues
but I didn't know that's what they were.
I would just feel overwhelmed in settings
with loud music or bright
lights, and I never knew why.
And then I also struggled a lot
with making friends and social situations
with like even listening and
understanding tone of voice
but I didn't know what any of this was.
And I spent my whole childhood
up until recently not knowing.
So yeah, it's a bit of
how, how that came about.
- I can only imagine how
that would have, you know
really crippled you socially,
you know, growing up
and not knowing how to, you
know, having any tools I guess
to get through that, those
emotions and those hardships.
So is this true though, that
of TikTOK video led to your diagnosis?
- Yes, it was.
I was on TikTOK and
for some reason the algorithm
decided to show me stories
like back to back stories
of women who had been diagnosed as adults.
And I was like, wait a minute.
I don't know anything
about this, but they saw
it sounds like they're
describing my whole life.
So that is what gave
you the courage to get
on Google and find a
specialist in my area.
And thankfully I was able to find someone.
So yeah, that's what led me
to be able to get diagnosed.
- Wow. A TikTok who would
have thought that's amazing.
So well, you have a new book?
And first I have to show
people how beautiful it is.
It is just such a beautiful book.
I mean the art in it, like it's so pretty.
So can you tell us about this?
Like what made you want to do this book?
- Yeah, so I am a visual
artist and a poet.
And especially over this
past year, like many people
I haven't been able to do a lot
of the things that I love to do.
I love to go places and see new things.
So art for me has been a way
of really just expressing gratitude
for what has been beautiful
about my story, what I have
how I have learned, how I have grown.
And I just think
that we all need these moments
right now, more than ever
of just having gratitude
for how far we've come.
So I hope that the poetry and art
in this book can help
people reflect on that.
- I love the message too, because a lot
of people would say how far we need to go.
And I actually, my therapist
told me this recently TMI
but it's like, I always focus on, Oh God
I still have to do
this. I have to do this.
I really want.
And she's like, why don't we
look at like, where you've come
from? Like, you know, like from this point
to this point, like, and
it's an amazing thing
but I think a lot of us, some
of us might be perfectionist.
So, but how far you have come
by Morgan Harper Nichols.
Y'all it's out right now.
If you can't get yourself a physical copy.
It is beautiful.
Thank you so much, Morgan
for sharing your story with everybody.
- Oh, well thank you for having me.
Thank you.